les américains n'auraient pas pu
imaginer pire scénario il faut rallier
n'ont pas même encore terminé leur
retrait d'afghanistan que les talibans
marche déjà sur kaboul balle mal de mark
ronson dans une adresse à la nation le
président afghan a insisté sur
l'importance de mieux mobiliser les
troupes afghanes avant de lui même sans
fuir quelques heures plus tard pour at
il dit éviter un bain de sang
la prise du pouvoir par les talibans ne
fait maintenant plus de doute mais le
secrétaire d'état américain maintient
toujours que les états unis ont pris la
bonne décision en se retirant
rester en afghanistan est exposé nos
troupeaux feu des talibans dit il il
aurait fallu de nouveau engagé le combat
empêche à washington on s'étonne de voir
les quelques trois cent mille membres
des forces afghanes entraînées et
équipées à grands frais par les
américains offrir si peu de résistance
cet échec encore une fois était
prévisible pourquoi parce que c'est une
armée qui est construit pas une
puissance occupante ou perçues comme
telles par ceux là même sur lesquels on
a voulu compter pour construire cette
arme et l'a donc leur débâcle face aux
talibans exprime beaucoup plus leurs
faiblesses que la puissance des talibans
l'administration badine et suis pourtant
les attaques nourrit de ses adversaires
ce républicain comparé l'évacuation de
l'ambassade américaine à la chute de
saigon au vietnam en 1975
cet autre parle d'un échec épique le
président dit il aura du sang sur les
mains
la maison blanche a contre attaqué par
une déclaration écrite le président bart
hayden rappelle que la décision de
retirer les troupes a été prise par
l'administration trump rester en
afghanistan encore plusieurs années ne
servirait pas l'intérêt national dit il
ajoutant que des mines de vie de jeunes
américains seraient mises à risque ici
hugo lavallée radio canada à washington